الانتخابات في جورجيا هذا العام لها
خصوصيه شديده فكما نرى او سنرى قد تحسم
الولايه الاغلبيه لاحد الحزبين في مجلس
الشيوخ بين المرشحين الجمهوري هيرشي الوكر
والديمقراطي رافاييل وورد ايضا الولايه او
للولايه ذاتها تاثير كبير على نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه فالفائز
بها يحصل على 16 صوتا في المجمع الانتخابي
هذه خريطه نتائج انتخابات في ولايات
الجنوب الشرقيه عام 2016 بين هيلاري
كلينتون ودونالد ترامب كما نرى ذهبت
جميعها الى المرشح الجمهوريه
ايضا تظهر نتائج الولايه في انتخابات عام
كل هذه الولايات ذهبت لترامب ما عدد
جورجيا وهو الامر الذي لم يعني يصدقه
ترامب بل دعاه بعد ذلك للزعم بوجود تزوير
في تلك النتائج من ابرز العوامل التي
تسببت في هذه النتيجه جهود الديمقراطيه
ستيسي ابرامز المرشح الديمقراطيه لمنصب
حاكم جورجيا في سباق الانتخابات الحالي
ستايسي ابرامز خاضت سباق على منصب حاكم
جورج
في عام 2018 وخسرت نفس السباق يتكرر بين
الاثنين هذه الانتخابات حينما خسرت ستايسي
عملت على تسجيل الناخبين من ذوي الاصول
الافريقيه في كشوف الانتخابات ليكون قوه
دفعا للديموقراطيين وبالفعل نجحت في تسجيل
800,000 ناخبا جديد يعتقد ان هذه الاصوات
التي سجلتها هي ما تسببت في فوزي جودا
بولايه جورجيا في الانتخابات عام 2020